as predicted the trade war effectively
launched by Donald Trump by putting
tariffs on steel and aluminum is
starting to ramp up China is now jumping
right in on this not only has Donald
Trump announced that there will be
tariffs on imported steel as well as
aluminum but now Trump has announced a
new list of specific Chinese imports
that are going to be targeted and in
response the Chinese government
completely expected Lee completely
predictably has announced new tariffs on
more than 100 American products this is
going to be a 25% tariff it will include
all sorts of products including cars
whiskey soybeans corn wheat various
types of beefs and meats orange juice
tobacco of different kinds a variety of
different textiles and chemicals and a
number of different industrial products
this immediately hit American stock
markets Dow futures prior to today's
opening down more than 500 points the
market very very erratic throughout the
day and I've said it before and I'll say
it again it's really difficult to win a
trade war and you've got a lot of
trumpets cheering that we're making
products more expensive for the Chinese
okay but they might not realize how much
of our stuff goes to China and how much
our economy and American businesses
depend on Chinese purchases of our
products China's population is 1.4
billion almost and every year their
middle class grows significantly in raw
numbers their upper middle class grows
significantly in raw numbers and the
demand the number of people in China
that want to buy American stuff American
beef or corn oranges it's really big and
when you make everything 25% more
expensive that is going to decrease
demand drastically and exporting to
China is a huge market for American
companies they're going to get crushed
because China is putting these tariffs
on our products and this is not me
saying China's never done anything wrong
China is just a panacea as far as a
global trading partner now there's lots
of criticisms to make of China we can
talk about unfair trade
practices from China which Donald Trump
claims to know about although really
it's just a talking point for him we can
talk about China's are arguable theft of
intellectual property from other
countries including the United States
this is not China is perfect
but just starting to put tariffs on
stuff is effectively it a race to the
economic bottom that's going to be
horrible for American farmers it's going
to be terrible for American
manufacturers and businesses of all
kinds in the United States and to give
you a sense of the scale here because
again China 1.4 billion people almost
United States 320 330 million in
population China is putting a tariff on
about a hundred products from the United
States Trump's tariffs list for China is
way way bigger
but the Chinese list encompasses about
half of all American exports to China
whereas the very long list of Trump's
products represents only about 10% of
Chinese exports to the United States so
right away you see how this is not
exactly a situation that Donald Trump is
setting the United States economy and
the United States business community up
to win and it's already setting the
United States up to get get crushed
American companies are not going to do
well here American consumers are going
to have to pay higher and higher prices
for a lot of stuff cut technical term
stuff but it comes from China and more
than likely you're going to see the
political repercussions be that the
committed trumpet
blames China instead of Donald Trump
who's actually the one who sort of
started this thing now the trumpets will
also say David it's unfair to say if
that Trump is actually the one who
started this because Trump was handed a
situation that President Obama could
have done something about when it comes
to trade imbalances and different issues
with trade and he didn't
so Trump is not the catalyst here Trump
is being thrown into this thing
midstream now that being said there are
also ways for the Chinese to sort of
circumvent the tariffs and keep selling
their cheap goods to the United States
one way which is done with some free
Quincy is that the Chinese products
which would have a tariff on them if
brought directly to the United States
can be sold to another country India
Malaysia and there they can be
effectively repackaged as Indian or
Malaysian goods and sold to the United
States and so you can very quickly see
how this is gonna be bad really bad for
the American economy and I generally
question the predictive ability of
economists right economists have proven
time and again to be pretty incompetent
at making economic predictions
particularly a couple of years out but
there are discussions of triggering a
sort of 2008 style recession of this
continues and I'm not you know some
people on the right leg to say the left
is cheering for America to fail and for
a recession merely so that they can say
we were right about Trump that's not me
that's never been me and I stand to lose
just like everybody else through paying
higher prices for products stock market
losses as people know I basically am
invested widely in mutual funds that
encompass the entire stock market I
don't pick stocks
so I'm not cheering nor hoping for a
problem for the American economy but
there are starting to be discussions
about what might be a pretty serious
recession and the early stock market
numbers today are not good not good in
the sense of being scary send me your
thoughts on this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and we'll be talking about
this and a lot of other related topics
online as well as on our subreddit
support for today's show comes from
hello fresh the meal kit delivery
service that will shop plan and deliver
your favorite step-by-step recipes and
pre measured ingredients so you can just
cook eat and enjoy you can choose from
the classic veggie and family plans the
boxes are delivered right to your door
and recyclable insulated packaging made
up of fresh responsibly obtained
ingredients carefully selected farms or
the sources high rated trusted sources
plus with the simple recipes outlined on
the pictured step-by-step instruction
cards
even I feel confident that I'm making
the recipes correctly a lot of one-pot
recipes that require minimal cleanup you
can spend less time meal planning you
don't have to throw out that leftover
piece of ginger or those extra rutabagas
that you don't know what to do it I hate
throwing food out and because the
ingredients are pre measured with
hellofresh you don't have to and I
particularly like the box I recently got
had some of the one pot meals and I love
making more intricate and complex meals
but I tend to like to do that on the
weekend when on a Tuesday night it's
time to make dinner and I've got two
skillets and three sauce pans out
nobody's happy I'm not happy I can
assure you my girlfriend isn't happy
story for another day though and so that
is why it makes it extra good to have
the one pot meals and you can get $30
off your first week of hellofresh
by going to hellofresh com entering the
coupon code Pakman 30 that is PA que ma
n30 for $30 off your first week of
hellofresh